one of the effects of the glorious
weather that we had this week and then
today was hailing so i don't know i
don't know what's going on it's spring
in the pacific northwest um is the
amount of pollen
is unbelievable we are surrounded here
uh
gratefully uh we are in the forest and
so we have a certain amount of the
evergreens for which washington state is
named for which the college that we were
once tenured at was named um things like
western red cedars and doug furs and
noble furs and
and such and um and others no pines um
but a lot of a lot of those but and and
uh but white right now we've got um the
most common
deciduous tree sometimes called a big
leaf tree broadleaf broadleaf tree i
guess uh is a big leaf maple and we've
got a lot of them here and
it's a periodical green
it's a periodical cream yeah it's
deciduous which is also known as
periodical um
and they are just they are they are
horny this week
they are having a lot of pollen
the male bits yeah we don't know about
the females i haven't asked yeah i
haven't i didn't ask the men either
the men trees didn't need to they no i
don't i should not i should not play
with the word man like that but i didn't
ask the male trees either but here they
are in you know everything every surface
i was i put my hand on a windowsill
like oh and our beautiful black cat is
coming inside his toes yellow his brump
yellow so we have a anyway
this little
in the throat is about pollen right now
well i actually i'm gonna pat myself on
the back here physiologically for you or
you could but that's weird here's the
thing
um i have had pretty severe allergies
and we are having a hell of a pollen
season yes we are um
so far i got it under control you know
this this this is of course a
conversation that could go lots and lots
of places but you know i know i never
had seasonal allergies at all
and uh just in the last couple of years
i you know i don't i'm not sneezing my
eyes aren't watering particularly but i
definitely feel it in my throat which is
where anything will go when it when i
get got
any kind of pathogen or your immune
system thinks it's a pathogen and it's
going to go after it even though it
shouldn't
um so that that is interesting because
really we had
every window in the house thrown open
for both the perfectly glorious day and
the slightly cooler day that preceded it
and as a result uh pretty much
everything in the house is yellow now
it's all coated in pollen it's all it is
all coated in pot
i will just mention that uh after i had
had covid in our recent bout um i had
lingering stuff for a long time uh i
thought it might be long covered it may
have been a little bit of long cover
medium covered
but at some point um
the symptoms that i had experienced when
i was still eating wheat that i had not
known were symptoms of a wheat allergy
started coming back and i was kind of
ignoring it and then the symptom that is
the most conspicuous to me it's not the
worst symptom by far but
the numb hands when i'm sleeping
came back and it was like okay wait a
minute am i eating wheat somewhere that
i don't know and i started eliminating
things that had shown up you know in the
right time frame that they could
plausibly have been
and nothing nothing nothing until
finally
i cut out all of the supplements that we
have been taking um
to prevent covet and other diseases dc
magnesium zinc right
and i got better very quickly and i
think i think what happened is i was
stuck in a
inflammation site one of those
supplements has something in it well i'm
pretty sure i'm i'm hesitant to test
this because it's going to involve me if
i'm right it's going to involve me
messing myself up again but
what happens and it's not the first time
i've been here you think a supplement
doesn't have any wheat because it
doesn't say wheat anywhere on the label
but unless it says something like
certified gluten-free which in my case
is a weird thing because i don't think
it's gluten as we've talked about here
before it's a it's some other molecule
in wheat
unless it says that if it says something
like vegetable um
um
gelatin
right that is to say gelatin of a
non-animal origin
that can contain wheat without them
saying the word and so i don't know if
that's what happened but it turned out
that the vitamin d of which i was taking
a substantial amount does say
vegetable gelatin on it and so anyway
i'm now in the uncomfortable position of
scientifically the right thing to do is
to go back on it and see what happens
but from the point of view of like
living a life it does it's not an
exciting prospect to me right
well and at least um from the
perspective of but what are you going to
do for your d levels we're now in the
time of year when uh we can when the sun
is high enough in the sky for enough
hours a day that you can actually
generate d here um in at what are we at
40
i don't know exactly what our latitude
is actually that's strange but it's 40
something it is
40 something for sure i want to say 45
46 i'm not actually sure i may be off by
a couple of degrees
um
but i guess it's over um any place over
35 degrees north or south of 35 degrees
south there's some period of the year
when um the sun is simply never high
enough in the sky on any given on any
day um for you know some some days weeks
or months in the winter that you can
generate d at all
but we are um we are out of that period
now and it's warming up and at least you
don't need the d in order to have the d
in your system yeah now for those of you
wondering
about what this means about where you
live i um
we have recommended and i'm going to
recommend even more strongly an app
called d minder
d minder allows you to know when in the
year you can start making vitamin d when
in the day you can start and when it is
no longer possible based on your
location it allows you to integrate
things about your own physiology anyway
it's a very it's a little bit difficult
to understand but it is worth investing
the time in this thing so i just went on
it for the first time
after i was out for you know two hours
on the water like okay let's let's see
what that means you know for
for me and yeah you can plug in a whole
lot of stuff about your age and your
weight and your height and because you
know the the heavier you are the heavier
set you are
the slower your d acquisition um and the
older you are the slower your
deacquisition and the darker your skin
the slower your de-acquisition and there
are some other things too but you don't
need to include any of that right um the
the thing that it can tell you that is
like clear simple quantitative data
uh is just tell it where you are and it
will know therefore um what your
latitude is doesn't care about longitude
and um well it doesn't care about
longitude with regard to d but also if
you tell it exactly where you are with
regard to latin longitude it'll tell you
it should be able to figure out or you
should tell it how high you are your
altitude because
basically the less atmosphere between
you and the sun the faster you make d as
well and of course the faster you burn
so there's a trade-off always
but
having a sense of okay given where i am
and what day of the year it is
what is the you know is there a window
in which i could be making d from the
sun and what is it and it's useful okay
one last thing here um what i think we
have learned as we have built up our
understanding on d is that
supplementation is important for people
who live above a certain latitude
because we're almost all deficient
in the part of the year
right but
supplementation is not a great
replacement for self-made photosynthetic
vitamin d that's right and so the point
is one of the things that this i was
looking at this app when i was out on my
bike ride
i was looking at when in the year you
can start making it turns out to be the
day before my birthday february 20th is
for portland the day you can start
making vitamin d how much can you make
very little how much are you likely to
make almost none why because february is
cold and so you even if you go outside
and even if it's sunny both of which you
know are
iffy at any given moment in portland um
the
chances that you'll make substantial
vitamin d are very low the number of the
idea being because it's cold you're
covered up right and so you know the
more of your skin is exposed the more
vitamin d you're making right so
in any case we are something like 100
days into our uh
no no
50 45 45 or 50 days into a
200 and i have to look at the app to
figure out exactly how many total days
there are but the point is
knowing
if the point is you want to make vitamin
d that your you will then store in
adipose tissue which will then be
released over the winter when you can't
make vitamin d right then the point is
well there's a clock ticking in terms of
how long you have to do it and in fact
the clock in which it's practical to do
it is pretty short because it's when the
sun is shining it's warm enough for you
not to be overly covered up and knowing
that is a is a power tool with respect
to
um
total vitamin d you can produce
absolutely and i mean i was thinking
about this too it's it's it's been a
trope
uh for a long time that you know people
old people on the east coast
um go to florida in the winter right uh
and
uh you know we grew up we grew up in la
which actually it turns out is at a
latitude where you can make d all year
round um which i didn't know until i
looked at this app right um
but the idea and you know and lots of
people who aren't old um
who you know may or may not be spending
the entire winters in florida uh will
vacation in in the caribbean in florida
for a week and you know we we know that
it feels good i mean this isn't
something that we ourselves have done
but you know we've done similar things
um
you know
obviously when it's cold out and you're
stuck inside and it's gray and it's dark
what you're craving is a blast of heat
and blue sky and just ease right
but
it's that is partially
your body telling you you need this this
is good for you this is healthy for you
and it's it's novel in that to go from a
place where you're making no d at all
and therefore if you're caucasian you're
probably really really white and the
first day you go out you're going to get
burned and then the rest of your
vacation is going to be kind of
miserable because you got burned the
first day so you have to be much more
careful than you would be if you were in
a place that had just a fluctuating
level of d with a fluctuating height of
uh the sun in the sky over over the year
you have to be more intentional about
your exposure as you first begin to get
exposed as i did you know on this
on this just you know two two and a half
hours out on the water um but it was the
first time that my shoulders had seen
the sun in i don't know five months it's
a long time
and
um
it just it reminds me that even many of
our modern cultural things that seem
cute
not very serious
um may well be driven by our bodies
actually informing us of what they need
yeah uh and actually this will come up
as we get into some of the other content
here but
you know
there is a way in which
uh
tan
for a caucasian person tan looks
healthier right
um
that may be about something and we may
have gone through a long period in which
um
frankly what we now should understand is
paranoia over sun exposure it's not that
sun exposure causes cancer it's that sun
burns cause cancer and you can have sun
exposure without a sunburn right
learning to modulate that may be a key
skill for
life
and you know and this has huge
implications also
for
things
flu is much less of a deal in the
tropics right
why
well vitamin d production is uh
possible all year round okay well that's
good why did
covid hit so hard in uh was it guayaquil
well in guayaquil if it's in the tropics
in a place you know it's near the
equator right well right guy kill is
really unpleasantly hot and humid and so
i'm not saying that this is what
happened but my hypothesis about what
happened in guayaquil would be that the
capacity to make vitamin d was
overwhelmed by people acquiring air
conditioners which dehumidify and cool
buildings and in that hot sticky
environment if you're not just sort of
condemned to hot and sticky and you get
used to it and you stop noticing it but
there's a place to retreat that's cool
and drier right people will tend to do
it so what i would love to know and the
prediction of the hypothesis
is that actually there's vitamin d
deficiency in guayaquil that
for example didn't uh it doesn't
match what there is in quito which is at
high altitude is naturally cooler and
drier is a great place to make vitamin d
because it's less atmosphere between
between you and the sun
so anyway these are all parsable
questions but the fact that there is
generally less of this issue in the
tropics right with interesting
exceptions suggests a pattern to be
learned from
[Music]
you